thanks to solver
two hairs little chat we've got going on
just to introduce myself my name is
Robert Fernandez and I've been in
Netflix a little over six years I spent
four years as an engineer in the open
connect group working on content
delivery and for the last two years I
stepped into a leadership role to manage
the tools team that helps build
solutions and automations for open
connect so I'm going to kind of give you
a whirlwind tour of things about a CDN
why it's important what it's actually
its purpose is why open connect was
built and determined to leverage and
build that within Netflix itself and
then kind of just run through a bit of
what my team does what kinds of
solutions that we try to solve what kind
of problems we try to solve within
Netflix and give an interesting spin
there so let's begin from the top so who
here believes they're familiar with a
CDN and what its purpose is what it's
all about but say they're very familiar
with it vaguely familiar yeah that's
that's fair so essentially this is a
broad definition of what a content
delivery network also knows content
distribution network as you may have
heard it delivery seems to be the more
common terminology and phrase used it's
just the process of taking a bunch of
content servers distributed them
geographically to get content closest to
those who are requesting and needing to
have the content and then providing a
means in a ways to direct those who are
requesting the content do get it from
the right place the most efficient place
be that the most efficient server and/or
network path so to kind of break that
down a little bit and give kind of a
high-level this is a grossly
oversimplified view of the internet
especially from the you know residential
space where there are a bunch of end
users who are connected with ISPs that
actually deliver them
and then there's larger more aggregated
networks that kind of interconnect those
providers together and you know some of
those smaller providers and bigger
providers are kind of aggregated into
one we think of something like Comcast
or whatever but that's generally how it
works and so if you want to do something
like deliver a piece of content like
stranger things
well the options just throw it up at one
of those more collective places so if
you put that in one of those more
aggregated locations there could be
potential unhappiness for you as a user
for obvious reason it may take you a
long time some kind of delay in getting
the content network hiccups
interruptions so the further away the
content is from you the harder it is for
you to get it however this also can make
actual providers somewhat unhappy as
well which is the part that some folks
tend to miss and the reason for that
being is that once you get to that level
and it's providers talking to other
providers that content that's deliver is
actually metered so there is a cost to
the typically megabits or gigabits per
second there's some kind of money
transfer that changes hands based on the
bits that are being delivered between
those providers also those things when
they have lots of traffic can of course
get congested so when you're talking
about something like Netflix which is
delivering streaming media which can be
very large file sizes it has been
measured at over one-third of the u.s.
Internet traffic during peak hours so
that means like 33 percent of all the
bits that are being delivered are coming
from Netflix sources during those times
so that means the Internet can actually
be broken in pretty amazing ways when
you try to shove a whole bunch of that
data through you know very singular
locations so
alternatively this is what we do we take
that content we distribute it on servers
that are closer to the users residing
with the ISPs in many cases which now
kind of frees that up you have a better
user experience we have more efficient
delivery the ISPs are happy because
we've minimize their costs we've
minimized congestion the transit
connectivity that they have to provide
and we haven't broken the internet so
yeah this is something it's a pretty
standard problem that many companies are
trying to be good stewards and solves of
course Netflix is one of them but I
think about YouTube Apple and their
store for delivering updates and their
own media Facebook so there's a whole
consortium of companies that say like
hey this is this is the thing we need to
solve because it's a better experience
for our users and just a better cost
savings and efficiency if we do things
this way so open connect let's talk a
little bit about why that exists and how
it came about in this whole Netflix
streaming story so can explain where
this fits in the entire picture you load
up Netflix and you actually want to you
know it's time for you to sit down and
consume some content the first thing is
you just start up the application
whatever device you have it on your TV
or mobile device it goes through an
initialization process to kind of
basically get the app up and running it
does some authentication this is where a
lot of the well-known things of like hey
Netflix works a lot with AWS a lot of
the computers in the cloud this is where
a lot of the services run so this is
where that starts to begin once all that
set up you're now ready to figure out
what it is that you want to watch so you
do your browsing you're searching you
look through your recommendations and
decide when you're ready for what we
call playback so once you've hit that
play button and it started to say hey
fetching content this is where content
delivery picks up and kicks in
and so this is where we sit in that
content delivery area and then once the
content has started streaming there's
then some interaction between the
clients and the content delivery
networks basically to make sure that you
have an optimal experience even as
network conditions might change or as
you're watching something you know
things can go up and down and we want to
make sure that you're not rebuffed 'red
that like the play experience is very
smooth so there's a bit of communication
between the two to make sure that that
happens
another small interesting tidbit is that
without content delivery in the mix it's
not just the actual streaming content
itself but all of the boxart the
trailers the screenshots everything that
you see there is delivered via the CDN
also the actual JavaScript assets which
are loaded into the application and
actually make the application run are
part of content delivery as well so it's
very multi tenant service at this point
that has multiple functions and so it's
about making the application function
and also delivering the content at this
point so Netflix streaming launched in
2007 in 2009 this is essentially the
story of what things look like there was
the Netflix content control plane NCCP
that was basically this dreaming part of
the Netflix products that was a kind of
second bullet of what a CDN is that was
the cloud functionality provided to make
sure you were steered to the right place
to get the content however the actual
delivery of that content was done by
aggregate of third-party providers that
we use to actually deliver that content
for us so we just had to make sure we
handed the content to the right places
those providers put it on the edge for
us and we just had to make sure that
when you click Play you got to the right
place to have it delivered from someone
who had the content however
fast forward a couple of years and this
is when Netflix opened connect was
launched very enterprising individual
within the company had some
conversations with Reid and some of the
product leadership and basically said
look we have a lot of experience working
with these CDN providers we know how
this works
we believe we could provide a similar
solution that's custom built for Netflix
that would be more efficient and better
for the business if we were to kind of
build this as opposed to buy it so what
that meant was well beyond the fact of
first we just had to deal with getting
you to the right content that other
folks were providing of that we now
became responsible for the entire
end-to-end process of getting those
servers into the right places making
sure the content was there and making
sure those servers were up and running
and doing the right things so that kind
of expanded the whole scope of what was
being done we're in relation to content
delivery inside of Netflix drilling in a
little bit - what that physically looks
like and I'm gonna say this because I
can't stop myself from saying open
connect appliance or o-ca just being
ingrained and open connect for so long
so if you hear me reference that all
that means is that is the actual
physical servers that we're using which
store the content that is delivered to
the end-users and there are actual a
couple of different varieties of that we
have what's known as our storage
appliance which essentially is for
storing large bits of the catalog on
spinning hard disk drives so that's
where we try to hold the majority of
things none of these including stacks of
them generally hold the whole catalog
they hold portions but for the majority
of things that aren't necessarily the
most fetched or the most popular we can
get away with storing them on these
drives that can hold more content but
may not be quite as efficient at reading
or writing or don't necessarily have as
much throughput
but does a job for the majority of
things and alternatively we also have a
another version that it's a flash
appliance which instead of spinning
drives have these spinning platters and
have arms that you know move and read
off of the disks they're solid-state
drive so they are not quite as efficient
cost wise in their stories capacity
however their throughput is actually
much greater their performance is much
higher so it's then finding a balance of
how do we build out the right sites that
have the right amount of flash or
offload appliances versus storage that
can get the right amount of content
based on the user base that it's trying
to serve and what catalogue we need to
have in those locations this is
currently all of the places where Open
Kinect has deployed servers we have
thousands of sites over 10,000
appliances the indication there of those
different color variants is we actually
have two types of sites the green ones
are ones where we have what we call an
embedded agreement where we actually
take those servers and we hand them off
to the ISPs they provide the space rack
power cooling and all the things to
actually maintain the server physically
and then we connect with them via their
own infrastructure the orange locations
are Netflix IX or internet exchange
locations where Netflix actually
controls and manages the hardware and
it's in some general location where
other ISPs exist and have connectivity
and we just via network we just peer
with them and we're the ones who
actually deliver the content for them
but as you see the Mast vast majority of
the OCS that we have deployed are
actually in embedded locations
throughout the world it was no of those
reasons that the efficiency of building
the solution within Netflix made so much
more sense because we were able to reach
other parts of the globe as Netflix
scale that believe was in 2016
when we did the global launch we
announced 130 additional countries to
the service now as of this year we're
over 190 countries so making sure we
have the content in the right places for
what parts of the catalog are in those
parts of the world is something that we
can just much better solve internally
than trying to hand that off to another
provider it's not just about servers
there's also a network component
involved so what this map is is of the
Netflix backbone network where we have
connectivity to make sure that we are
able to efficiently fill contents
basically what Phil means is given that
these locations can't store all of the
catalog that's needed they just try to
find the most efficient offload to get
the most content off of transit as
possible but that changes over time as
new things are released as things get a
little older may fade in popularity
which content we want in which places
changes so there are some processes that
run to make sure we know what things
need to be in the right place in the
future and the OCA is basically found
home and say what is it that you want me
to have on my system and then during
off-peak hours when most want everyone
in their own time zone is asleep there's
not a lot of traffic costs actually go
down for some of this more like type of
transit activity because there's no
congestion that is when most of the new
content that needs to be in place
happens so we need to make sure we have
good network connectivity to get these
large files to the right places so that
they're in place it's a tiered mechanism
so that there's a few locations that do
store the entire catalog they dump the
right things into current regional
locations and then they essentially just
peer fill between themselves so if
there's 30 machines in a stack only a
couple of them actually have to fit
fetch the content and the other 28 can
just fetch it locally from within its
own local network to kind of again save
so that's a bit of history about CD ends
about open connects now I'm going to
talk a little bit about what it is that
our team does and how we came about so
within the open connect organization
they're just kind of some natural
verticals that kind of grew out of
having to take over all of these parts
of content delivery what parts of the
business were actually established so
there's a development group that
basically is in charge of specking out
what these revisions of hardware are
that we're going to deliver on about
annual basis there's typically one or
two new revisions of each hardware type
that kind of come out that we deliver on
that have new components new
technologies so we're constantly keeping
that up to date there's a group of folks
who work on the actual firmware the OS
that runs on these machines which is a
custom fork of FreeBSD back probably a
whole separate talk of like why we
actually choose and what that OS looks
like and why we do that but there's many
reasons and then there's the group
that's actually building out the control
plane so that was all the kind of stuff
we were talking about with the CDN but
if you actually want to run this thing
there are many more things involved we
talked about the network which is kind
of the last picture that I've shown that
there's making sure we're provisioning
the right network things and getting
good cost for those over time as the
landscape changes there's an Operations
component so you know we actually have
to make sure this thing is up and
running
that it's doing the right things and
that we have the right communications
setup with partners so that we can make
sure things are going right on there and
for the ones that actually do have the
embedded OSI A's in their installations
and then just general business
operations type of things doing CRM
shipping things around managing these
these partnerships with all of these
ISPs there's a lot of logistics around
that and making sure all the right
things are happening from the business
sense and what kind of organically
happened
it's that as these groups were kind of
growing and finding their purpose and
what they needed to do they wanted to
start building some tooling and
automation so essentially kind of each
group had their own small sub team that
was kind of looking to solve the
problems for what was going on kind of
in that vertical within open connect
kind of was discovered that that wasn't
scaling entirely well and that there
might be some efficiencies gained by
collectively combining those groups into
one who could kind of look at the
overarching set of needs within open
connect as a whole and trying to build
more general solutions that could handle
some of these you know cross-functional
concerns or kind of step out and make
sure there wasn't any duplicate effort
between these groups and the types of
tooling that they needed and so on and
so forth so hence this team was born and
essentially what our Charter is is to
design and build solutions to open
connect operate us one of the keywords
more efficiently and reliably so what
exactly does that mean and what is in
our scope kind of looks like this
we tend to focus on more of how the
business functions the Netflix user not
Netflix user the Netflix employee
experience and things that they are
dealing with on a daily basis to make
sure open connectors running and
functioning and delivering content and
when I mentioned the open connect
control plane that bit that's actually
the cloud service that actually decides
where within the CDN do you need to go
to get your content they have a set of
problems that they try to solve and that
is you know making sure that the right
content is and is getting to the right
places that all of the security and geo
things are in the right place Netflix
only serves certain parts of its content
to certain parts of the world just how
rights management works very much as
depending on where you are sitting
depends what you can actually watch on
Netflix and those who would like to
circumvent or get around that the people
who hold the likes of the content make
sure we're doing due diligence to
make sure when you log in you are who
you say you are and you are where you
say you are so that we're giving the
right things to the right people that we
are allowed to so those are the kind of
concerns that they deal with and we're a
little bit on the other more
business-related side so that's a long
list this is more of a picture of kind
of what that looks like these are the
kind of focus areas that we care about
inventory and hardware management so
working with our manufacturers and
system integrators actually build these
machines that middle thing represents
our fill site which what that represents
is before we ship these machines out to
these especially these embedded
locations we don't want to have the
partners plug them in and then suddenly
have to download terabytes and terabytes
it would take them days to like pull all
the content they need to get their
initial set of content loaded so we
actually send them to a well connected
place in the US we have them allocate
these machines are going to end up in
this location so please preload these
bits of content there because we know
once it gets out in the field in that
location that's what its going to want
so that the vast majority of the catalog
for where that machine is going is
already pre-loaded so that's a whole
process that we have to help manage of
getting the right things to the right
places make sure they get the right
things on them before they actually go
out to the partners and then the Bob
viously we have relationships with
communications partners ISPs who
actually are dealing with having this
inventory on hand and taking care of it
for us and then there's many other
things obviously we have to ship these
things around so we have carriers that
get these boxes from here to there we
have to manage those types of processes
and relationships the actual business
functions within Netflix do matter to
make sure we have the right legal
agreements in place before we actually
send something to a partner when we
actually are moving Hardware between
locations from us to a partner depending
on which country and what the legal
rules are there and accounting rules
like what happens when the Machine
changes hands who
dakotas the owner what entity owns it
making sure we have all of that accurate
and reflected based on the state of what
the CDN physically looks like is quite
important the actual operations of it
like I mentioned before the operations
team needs to be able to have insight of
are these machines alive doing the
things that they need to do we're
dealing with Hardware so of course it's
not a perfect world there's issues
things break things happen so then we
have to deal with what do we do when
those things happen how do we deal with
repairs how do we deal with our maze how
do we deal with end-of-life and cycling
the hardware that exists out in the
fleet so what had kind of organically
happened is of course in a group that's
growing very quickly there were a lot of
organic processes that came about and
unfortunately a lot of them were quickly
built solutions that looked of things
like a lot of spreadsheets a lot of just
kind of cobble together
scripts to kind of automate some of
these things there's always you know
software is never short-lived so always
you know someone I you know how to
gather a prototype of something that I
built we're only going to use it a
couple times and three years later
you're then trying to get rid of it
still is always fun and then just a lot
of manual processes of email back and
forth between different groups and
between partners actual phone calls
which are even worse to try to track
them you like what actually happened on
this call you know who actually
committed to what action had and what's
happening there's not a lot of insight
into those type of things so what we do
is we try to build you know more
standard solutions that are engineered
to help solve these problems so more
information systems services workflows
and automation that they will never
replace all of the other processes are
going on there's always going to be a
spreadsheet somewhere there's always
gonna be someone manually tracking
something somewhere there's always gonna
be phone calls happening we're not going
to automate in a way the world's we
don't
that kind of pipe dream but we would
like to make that as small as possible
so that those within Netflix who are
working on the CDN have the ability to
do that better so what does that look
like
essentially this likely looks somewhat
how like the business is structured
there were just some general natural
kind of verticals from a software
perspective that came out of this there
were applications that dealt with kind
of the hardware and inventory management
side of things another rather large web
application that dealt with like the
configuration management of like how do
you actually set the properties and
configure all these machines out on the
fleet to make sure they know what
they're supposed to be doing where
they're sitting from our operations side
monitoring obviously as we said before
was very important so that we were able
to have insight into what was going on
in the live running service and then a
bunch of other that last box there's
actually multiple applications kind of
thrown into one but essentially this is
what the landscape looked like for at
least a couple of years a very
three-tiered web application type of
stuff you know persistence layer
middleware API layer and then a UI that
would sit on top of it but relatively
siloed in the areas and as things were
needed they were just kind of added to
that application there were some
platform services that were kind of
built that were somewhat cross-cutting
concerns so like how we actually did all
of our logging how we did telemetry so
like you know as our UIs were being used
that we could see like we know what
users were doing where things were
failing so some of those services did
exist but in general it was quite a bit
of large three-tiered web applications
that got built and as you can see the
reason that top dashed line exists is
the vast majority we build is internal
to Netflix and is for you know Netflix
folks to operate the CDN and run the CDN
but we do have also a small external
basing component which are like some
self-service portals that we allow our
partners into so that they're able
actually to do some of these things of
maintenance and incite themselves and we
don't have to rely solely on our
operations team to do some of that so
I'm going to chat a little bit about
what is our process and what is our
thought in how we kind of get out from
under that historical architecture that
kind of just grew out of those silos
that were kind of built a little bit of
a disclaimer here we are not going to
say sign up here and say that you know
everything needs to be SOA or micro
services there's a time and a place
there is a reason that a lot of these
MVC server frameworks as exists asp.net
Grails Ruby on Rails spring MVC those
things exist for a reason those types of
you know opinionated and more patterned
constructs it's easy to ramp up of them
it's easy to understand there's a lot of
flexibility of as things have changed
you don't have to do the full view layer
within your server you could just
basically do kind of the model and
controller and serve things more like
web api set of these frameworks so that
they're there they do their job if
you've got a small scope project or a
small team this is a super easy way to
start building out applications yeah
they get leveraged for a reason however
if you start to deal with one of these
things long enough you might to notice
some of these warning signs a couple I
will call out specifically scaling
required for individual features is a
very interesting one where it's if you
have an application that deals with many
different types of functions say you're
just basically doing certain crud
operations you have some background jobs
that are kind of
running on some kind of scheduler that
are happening on the server you have a
Search API that was actually like
delivering filtered search results via
your API and you notice that perhaps you
start having to scale up or add more
capacity like solely for the intent of
search and that's making all of the
other parts of your application suffer a
bit because there's just some part of
your application that is taking up most
of the resources or compute time or
whatever the second last one also we
actually have seen a bit of when tech
ops greater than developments that
basically means if you're spending more
time trying to keep the system alive and
not disrupting other services and you
are actually developing and working on
the service it may be something that you
want to take a look at that last one is
really a long-running joke literally
within the team of when you start seeing
things in slack or s it was like is it
okay if I have this new feature am I
going to stomp on its toes if I push
this okay
can you watch this for me or no I have
to do yours after mine probably are a
little bit of a flag you should be like
oh is this really how we should have
this system running in the long term the
answer might be no so
this is at a high-level kind of what we
have come up with for our architecture
and path moving forward of going with a
more layered approach to how we actually
build and deploy these services so you
know for example we can start to
leverage things between the control
plane team and ourselves by just
building one solution of a gateway of
all the communication we have to do with
these o CAS if we have that all running
through one place in one service that is
built that middle layer that domain
layer is quite important to our future
moving forward of instead of having one
application that is dealing with a lot
of domains and a lot of different areas
that we start to decompose and break
those down a bit and kind of have
services that have one general concern
and one type of area that they need to
focus on so we can scale those services
independently we can remodel that
service independently and not have to
worry about affecting any of the other
services that we have built and like I
said that kind of tier on the very right
there is kind of some of those
cross-cutting concerns some of those
services already exist for us some like
for example I mentioned search we happen
to have search kind of distributed
within all those applications at this
point and we think we need a lot more
leverage if we extract that and had a
more common solution for searching all
of the entities that we provide via some
other mechanism but then there is still
the well now that you have all of these
services how do you deliver that
experience to clients or UIs and either
consume them which we'll get to in just
a minute so what this kind of boils down
to is that we are going from a more
application centric application focused
kind of architecture into just more of a
platform based one for kind of all the
reasons mentioned all those red flags
that were kind of noted those are all
ones that we've seen so we would like to
basically make our delivery
how easy it is for us to design and
deploy solutions we can do much more
efficiently much more independently and
not a lot of having to deal with large
complex dependencies large complex
interactions between things that live on
the same application and so on this also
lets us be very flexible and kind of
take a step back and say like ok one of
our charters moving forward is to look
at things like devices as not just OSI
A's but if we wanted to do inventory
tracking on devices in general let's say
Network Devices routers and things or
storage or compute devices we start to
add those to the fleet that we have the
ability to manage devices as devices
that can be general or more specific
devices can have components so if we
kind of extract that out and have its
own thing we can get more leverage and
power by having a service that deals
with that instead of OCS on one and
network devices another and having you
know like these separates very specific
types of solutions to a more generalized
one so what does that mean within the
area of user interfaces for us as I said
those are not unaffected as we start to
break this down and decompose these
applications what do we do with these so
the kind of highlight areas that we have
essentially an application UI
application / web application is kind of
essentially what it looks like at this
point in time there's a sub team that's
focused on that application they know
what the in general REST API czar for
that web application they know what UI
they need to build on it's a very much
one-to-one but we're looking to break
that apart so what does that look like
in essence we're kind of taking a step
back and it's essentially a bit more of
the opposite of what we want to do with
our service tier so rather than saying
we actually want to break these down and
have a UI per server that doesn't make
sense like these things still need to
interoperate
agregate
together tell a better story so rather
than looking at this from a domain or
service level we've kind of taken a step
back and said okay what are our main
user roles or user stories or use of
realtor you know like what types of
users do we support and then we'd like
to build us our applications around that
rather than this is the application this
is its API this is what the UI needs to
be built to serve that API so having
this stories of internal administration
which is most all of those UIs that were
kind of aggregated at that one layer
internally we'd like to be able to send
users to one logical place that may
actually be a composite of a few
different UIs but at least give them
like you know this is a place they can
go launched you and give them access to
all of the types of things they need to
do and not have to do Hardware type
things in this application and
configuration in this one and monitoring
in this one and where do I go to do what
it's something we'd like to alleviate
and then I still want to tell those
external like partner stories but in
that case you know we have two
essentially different types of partners
we have those ISP partners who are
helping deliver content for us and we
have those integrator portals which is
more like the manufacturers the fill
site they're kind of you know the behind
the scene folks that are dealing with
these machines before they get on to the
live service that's a bit of a different
experience that we want to deal with so
but what does that look like from a
technology standpoint what do we do when
we have all of these services and we do
need you eyes that need to talk to them
and there's a couple different options
one you can just go with a straight API
gateway approach there is a Netflix open
source project called Zul many of you
may have heard of it this is essentially
what fronts the actual Netflix service
itself when the client is communicating
with it goes through this gateway but in
that sense if that's your only solution
all that knows is the requests are
coming into one place and it's just
sending them off somewhat directly to
the services that are behind it
so it's essentially just like somewhat
unintelligent that all it knows is what
the structure of your services are like
where they actually live and what it
needs to get you to when you make a
request so second option is dealing more
with like APA aggregation composition
there's basically some layer somewhere
that actually can take that data and
combine it for you and some means that
give you a singular place to access that
again there's a Netflix open source
project they're called Falkor
that's what's leveraged kind of in
combination with Zul to deliver the
actual models from api ups of the
clients that we use however internally
within Netflix at least from the tools
perspective and who are building
internal solutions there actually is
another product that we project that we
started leveraging on - and that's graph
QL it has very much trying to solve the
same kind of problem that Falkor does
but in a slightly different way don't
have time to go into much detail here
but whereas something like Falkor can
give you back an object and kind of know
that to give you these objects it has to
go to different places to kind of
combine and give you that object back in
one form graph QL lets you be a little
more verbose about that and kind of say
here's what my data model looks like
it's a type system so you actually can
build types into it so if you're using
something like typescript or something
like that on UI making that translation
is actually very easy it allows you to
do introspection on your model there's a
little bit more powerful query interface
so instead of just saying I want these
sets of things or this range of things
you can actually apply filters of you
know I want things with this name in
these other fields that match this
filter and hand that back to me but in
essence that's the kind of layer that
will handle
dealing with all that for you of knowing
where all those services are that have
the individual bits of data combining
them and giving them back to you in one
place this started as a Facebook
initiative they use it internally and
that has kind of grown out now there
actually is a graph QL foundation there
are a lot of contributing community
members to that so it's a very thriving
community there's a lot of support as I
said there are a lot of groups internal
to Netflix that are actually beginning
to heavily leverage this just for all
the benefits it gives you of being able
to control what your model looks like do
you have a type declarative system of
what kind of data you're going to get
back and then how to build UIs around
that there's there's some very nice
stories there all right so hopefully
you're able to take a little bit of
something I know that was kind of a very
broad sweep of you know covering CDN
covering open connects covering open
connect tools itself if you have any
questions I'll be hanging around
afterwards kind of chat with folks I'll
also be heading over to our booth from
3:30 to 5:00 over in the Stifel theater
we have two booths on the third floor I
think if you want to stop by and chat in
the strange loop slack we have a Netflix
channel so if you'd like to hop in there
ask any questions ask anything about
Netflix or about up connects happy to
answer it then it's a little plug there
is another Netflix chat on pattern
matching with finite state machines
that's next door tomorrow afternoon so
if you want to hear a whole different
hard and different story about Netflix
and you already check that out also so
that's all I got
Thanks
[Applause]